a las vegas doctor readjusting to life
in the states again after spending
months volunteering in ukraine tonight
he spoke with victoria saha on why he
wanted to be there despite the ongoing
war with russia
the images of the destruction ukraine is
facing did not scare dr wilson bernalis
instead it pushed him to volunteer his
medical skills it was a harrowing dr
bernalis a family practitioner in the
las vegas area describes what he saw
firsthand when he was in ukraine the
devastation we were seeing on tv was
just a sliver of what he was facing this
old lady
with 21 bullet fragments
and we have to take them out
one by one in the in the office
you know and then we we asked her if she
wants to go to the hospital she said no
you know she was so frantic to get out
of ukraine
he said no no no i'm going to poland in
an undisclosed secret shelter dr
bernalis was stationed near the border
of poland where refugees would stop
before continuing their journey this
defenseless citizen especially women and
children
and i don't know how blood president
vladimir putin's sleep at night but the
crying screaming and panic dr bernalis
faced from the refugees trying to escape
ukraine was starting to affect him
earlier this month he decided to come
back home i felt a lot of guilt coming
home
you know but
i said
you know i did my part i was there for
three and a half months victoria saha
live local now
the doctor says he would like to return
to ukraine eventually and he encourages
other american doctors to help out as
well